I'll start with an update on the
progress we're making to beat the virus
before moving to an update on schools
the first slide shows the latest covert
alert level poco vid 19 alert level
across the United Kingdom has moved down
from level 4 to level 3 as recommended
by the joint biosecurity Centre for
chief medical officers for England
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland have
reviewed the evidence and agree with
this recommendation in all four nations
there's been a continuing steady
decrease in cases but this doesn't mean
that the pandemic is over the virus is
still in general circulation and
localized outbreaks are likely to occur
the second slide shows cases confirmed
with a test 7,000,000 430 3114 test for
corona virus have now been carried out
or posted out in the United Kingdom this
includes a hundred and sixty-nine
thousand six hundred tests carried out
or posted out yesterday three hundred
and 1815 people have tested positive an
increase of 1346 cases since yesterday
sage has confirmed today that their
estimate for VR rates for the United
Kingdom is unchanged on last week at
nought point seven to naught point nine
we want to keep the are number below 1 R
is the average number of additional
people infected by each infected person
the third slide shows the latest data
from hospitals 494 people were admitted
to hospital with corona virus in England
Wales and Northern Ireland on the 16th
of June down from 534 a week earlier
and down from a peak of 3432 on the 1st
of april 354 coronavirus patients are
currently in mechanical ventilation beds
in the United Kingdom down from 392 a
week ago and down from a peak of 3301 on
the 12th of April the fourth slide shows
what is happening in hospitals right
across the country there are now five
thousand and thirty people in hospital
with coronavirus in the UK down 10% from
5608 a week ago and down from the peak
of twenty thousand 699 on the 12th of
April as a graph show while there is
some variation most nations and regions
of the United Kingdom are broadly
following a similar pattern the fifth
slide shows the daily figures of those
who have sadly lost their lives after
testing positive for coronavirus across
all settings the total number of deaths
now stands at 42 thousand 461 that's an
increase of 173 fatalities since
yesterday
when measured on a seven-day rolling
average the daily number of deaths
currently stands at 140 down from a peak
of 943 on the 14th of April turning to
schools in March when we asked schools
to close we did something different from
virtually every other nation we made the
decision to keep schools open not just
for the children of critical workers but
also for those most vulnerable children
in our society this was because we
recognized the important role that
schools play in keeping those children
safe from the start of this month school
began to welcome back children from
nursery reception year 1 and year 6 as
part of a phased and cautious return and
from this week we started to sieve
return of years 10 and 12 we want as
many children and back in school as
possible which is why this week we
announced more flexibility for primary
schools so that they can have the
opportunity to bring back more of their
pupils if they're able to do so in line
with the protective measures that we've
already set out today with the
overwhelming majority of primary and
secondary schools as well as colleges
and nurseries opening to more children
young people I wanted to take the
opportunity again to say thank you thank
you to all the teachers childcare and
support staff who've done so much and
continued to do so much to welcome back
our children in a warm friendly
environment with a happy opportunity to
learn
I think all of us who've seen our
children return to school know that
they're enjoying being back in the
classroom and being with their friends
and their classmates school is vital for
every one of our children that is why we
will bring all children in all year
groups back to school in September while
many children have already returned to
school I do understand there is anxiety
still among parents I want to assure you
that the well-being of your children is
the absolute top priority for every
single one of us we've put robust
protective measures in place including a
hierarchy of controls and protective
bubbles and more stress that is in every
child's best interest to return to
school if they're eligible to and able
to this measured return is part of our
roadmap it's part of how we will recover
and rebuild after this virus but I think
all of us recognize how much children
have missed out and why it's so
important we support them to catch up on
this lost ground having open schools to
more pupils and set out our intention
for a full return in September the next
part of our recovery will be to roll out
our hugely ambitious catch-up plan for
all of our children we must get them
back to where they should be and put in
place a secure foundation for
longer-term reform will not allow an
entire generation to lose out on their
education or accepted lower expectations
for them that's why we're launching a 1
billion pound kovat catch-up plan
they'll lift outcomes for all pupils
with targeted support for those from
disadvantaged backgrounds who are most
at risk of falling behind because of
this disruption as part of this package
we'll provide a universal catch-up
premium worth 650 million pounds for all
state school children in England to help
them make up for the lost teaching time
in the next academic year the education
endowment foundation has published a
guide for schools on how the money could
be best spent which will include invent
intervention programs access to
technology or summer schools this crisis
will have affected children in many
different ways and for this reason I am
giving schools of a discretion to tailor
this funding towards their particular
needs and the needs of the children that
they teach the plan also includes a new
350 million pound national tutoring
program to increase access to high
quality tuition for disadvantaged
children and young people this will not
only help children in the short term or
create a positive long lasting legacy to
drive up standards expanding the number
of high quality
tutoring providers for all schools to
use this 1 billion pound package is
already on top of fourteen point four
billion pound deal over three years
announced last year going to our schools
recognizing there's our schools need
additional support at this difficult
time and helping them help students to
catch up over the coming weeks we'll
publish further information and guidance
to help schools prepare prepare for a
full return in September we're working
across government and with a sector to
ensure these plans are fully in place so
that this can happen and every child of
every year group has the benefit of a
first-class education the pandemic has
dealt an unprecedented shock to our
education system as it has to many other
parts of our national life although we
have a clear plan there will of course
be times when we have to respond quickly
to changing circumstances
if provide this virus has taught us one
thing it's the absolute importance of
being flexible and adaptable when we
have to be the education system has
shown that it can do this and do so much
more we all want to see every child back
in school and we'll work together to
make sure that we achieve this